I knew a guy he moved into an apartment  building like a real nice luxury Condo  building yeah with his girlfriend day  one in the elevator with his girlfriend  like literally getting the [ __ ] from the  U-Haul truck and the girlfriend saw an  ex-boyfriend she had in high school that  lived in the building what a quinky dink  him and his girlfriend he they moved out  of the building the next day broke the  lease and he left you know this person I  know this person personally I was like  what a dummy well the most insecure  person of all time obviously could you  imagine doing that yeah no I mean who  cares why the [ __ ] would you give a [ __ ]  I don't and also a lease to break the  lease is like thousands of dollars yeah  I can't deal with this I used to